rafik quand il est devenu premier baudis
avait fortune 3 milliards $
et quand il a quitté ses fonctions de
ministre
sa fortune était de 17 milliards de
dollars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
angela merkel reçu au fort de brégançon
aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron la
chancelière allemande et le chef de
l'état français ont échangé sur
plusieurs dossiers brûlants comme la
crise en biélorussie paris offre
d'ailleurs sa médiation dans ce dossier
mais aussi les tensions entre la turquie
et la grèce ou encore la libye assimi
goueta se présente désormais comme le
nouvel homme fort du mali ce colonel de
l'armée dit être à la tête du coup
d'état qui a renversé mardi soir le
président ibrahim boubacar keïta il est
toujours aux mains des militaires la
communauté internationale condamne le
putsch et demande un retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel
les chefs d'état de la cedeao se sont
réunis aujourd'hui par visioconférence
ou la présidence du président du niger
et ont décidé de l'envoi d'une
délégation spéciale à bamako rebond de
la fin des mythes kovy de 19 dans le
monde dans ce contexte l'australie lance
aujourd'hui le débat autour d'un vaccin
obligatoire
selon l' oms la perspective d'un nouveau
confinement strict s'éloigne en europe
pour l'organisation les états européens
sont mieux préparés à faire face à m
une vague en ce sens de 3700 nouveaux
cas recensés hier une progression
inédite depuis le mois de mai
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france
on débute avec la rencontre qui s'est
tenue au fort de brégançon entre
emmanuel macron et angela merkel
c'est la première fois que la
chancelière allemande se rend dans la
résidence de vacances du président de la
république
parmi les sujets abordés la pandémie de
kobe de 19 les situations critiques au
mali les tensions méditerranée ou encore
la biélorussie écoutez à ce sujet
emmanuel macron l'union européenne doit
continuer de se mobiliser aux côtés des
centaines de milliers de biélorusses qui
manifestent pacifiquement pour le
respect de leurs droits de leur liberté
de leur souveraineté
un dialogue entre les autorités
l'opposition et la société civile est à
cet égard indispensable nous souhaitons
que ce dialogue puisse être mise en
place par les biélorusses eux mêmes mais
l'union européenne se tient prête
néanmoins accompagné celui ci si notre
rôle de médiation peut être utile est
souhaitée par les biélorusses avec
d'autres institutions notamment l'eau
scee et en incluant la russie dans un
dialogue exigeant comme nous avons pu le
faire
madame la chancelière comme moi même et
encore ce matin le président charles
michel que ce que nous attendons de la
russie
c'est véritablement un dialogue franc et
sincère avec l'union européenne en
particulier l'allemagne et la france
c'est une coopération pour une médiation
efficace et c'est d'apporter sa pierre
pour éviter toute escalade et pour
surtout bannir absolument toute violence
l'additionnel dans la situation delos
très pauvre edouard husson historien
auteur de paris berlin la survie de
l'europe aux éditions gallimard la
question biélorusse fait ressortir des
divergences entre la france et
l'allemagne
je pense que l'allemagne souhaiterait
rester sur une stratégie qui
ressemblerait à l'attitude vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine et depuis la crise de crime et
emmanuel macron lui voudrait impliquer
la russie d'ailleurs par réalisme
il sait que aucune crise biélorusse ou
ukrainiennes ne peut se résoudre sans la
russie
donc c'est là aussi le filon de la
politique française
mais là encore pourquoi
leurs robes et derrière la rhétorique
européenne la france reste une puissance
et elle peut jouer un rôle elle peut
peser
elle peut dialoguer avec la russie elle
peut mettre des gens autour de la table
françois hollande l'avait l'avait bien
fait au moment de delà de la crise
craignait nez il avait obtenu les actes
de minsk après il les a peu défendu mais
la france a de l'influencé
si vous voulez pourquoi mettre sa
toujours sous le drapeau l'union
européenne sur le terrain en biélorussie
les autorités annoncent donc l'ouverture
d'une affaire pénale pour atteinte à la
sécurité nationale visant l'opposition
la contestation contre la réélection
d'alexandre loukachenko se poursuit
depuis bientôt deux semaines et sont
encore nombreux aujourd'hui dans les
rues de minsk sur ces images des femmes
réunies pour protester muni bouquet de
fleurs hier le président biélorusse a
réuni son conseil de sécurité tandis que
les 27 dirigeants l'union européenne
était un sommet extraordinaire
ils ont annoncé rejeter le résultat de
l'élection et prévoit des sanctions
contre des responsables biélorusses
alors quels effets pourraient avoir ces
sanctions précisément assez peu selon un
gilbert dr ho analyste politique
indépendant
les sanctions dirigées contre les
personnes ne sont pas sérieuses je ne
pense pas que les fonctionnaires
biélorusses puisse souffrir des
limitations qui seront imposées à leurs
droits de propriété et droit de voyager
après les sanctions des pays occidentaux
ce qui est extrêmement important ce sont
les 50 3 millions d'euros proposée par
le président du conseil européen charles
michel dans le contexte c'est une somme
d'argent énormes qui peut influencer les
esprits et les retourner contre leur
gouvernement
alexeï navalni l'activiste anti
corruption russe hospitalisé dans un
état grave il a perdu connaissance à
bord d'un avion il a été admis à l'unité
de soins intensifs du service de
toxicologie de l'hôpital d'omsk en
sibérie est placé sous respiration
artificielle
les médecins disent tout faire pour le
sauver mais ne manquerons s'est dit
préoccupé par sa situation il affirme
qu'il pourra recevoir toute l'aide
médicale en france il en fait la demande
selon le porte parole de l'opposant
politique ils auraient été empoisonnés
plus de précision avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
tout a commencé dans la matinée dans
l'avion qui ramenait alexeï navalni à
moscou depuis tomsk une ville située en
sibérie occidentale
peu après le décollage l'avocat de 44
ans a fait un malaise dans son
l'appareil à effectuer un atterrissage
d'urgence à l'aéroport d'omsk où il a
aussitôt été prise en charge par les
secours
sa porte parole qui l'accompagné lors de
ce voyage a fait savoir qu'il avait bu
qu'un verre de thé avant de monter à
bord et clame donc qu'il a été
empoisonné
une affirmation qui n'a pas été confirmé
par le médecin qui a pris en charge
alexeï navalni à omsk ce match et il
n'est pas du tout certain que son état
et été provoqué par un empoisonnement
l'empoisonnement naturel est considérée
comme l'une des causes possibles de la
détérioration de son état mais il peut
aussi y avoir un certain nombre
d'affections qui sont apparus de façon
aiguë et qui ont mené aux mêmes aspects
cliniques
nous travaillons sur toutes les
possibilités nous étudions son état
confirmant ce que nous avons constaté
mais je ne peux malheureusement pas vous
donner plus de détails pour le moment
à l'heure actuelle l'état avec senna
vanille est stable mais préoccupant
aucun diagnostic n'a encore été rendu
public pour le moment on le sait le
reboisement et donc l'hypothèse
privilégiée par l'entourage de
l'opposant politique et les enquêtes de
police n'exclut pas la possibilité qu'il
ait bu ou pris des substances la veille
au soir
quoi qu'il en soit du côté du kremlin on
suit également l'évolution de son état
de santé
oui les médias publient beaucoup
d'informations à ce sujet
donc nous lisons aussi ces informations
nous savons qu'il est dans un état grave
les médecins font tout ce qui est
nécessaire en ce moment les meilleurs
médecins sont impliqués et d'après ce
que nous apprenons des médias il utilise
des méthodes de télémédecine etienne des
consultations avec des spécialistes à
moscou bien entendu comme tout citoyen
de notre pays
nous lui souhaitons un prompt
rétablissement le propre médecin alexeï
navalni a fait savoir qu'il désirait que
son patient soit transféré vers un
hôpital spécialisé en allemagne ou bien
encore en france des négociations sont
actuellement en cours
dimitri peskov a d'ailleurs déclaré que
c'était possible et que son cas serait
loin d'être une exception
en effet malgré la fermeture des
frontières du à la pandémie de corolla
virus de nombreux citoyens russes
continuent de se faire soigner à
l'étranger
il reste maintenant à attendre les
résultats des analyses afin d'en savoir
plus sur les raisons de la dégradation
subite de l'état de santé d'un excellent
navalni l'une des voix les plus
critiques envers le kremlin les
situations au mali au coeur des
préoccupations internationale la cédéao
a annoncé l'envoi d'une délégation de
haut niveau à bamako pour le retour de
l'ordre constitutionnel
ils réclament le rétablissement ibrahim
boubacar kéïta comme président après le
coup d'état de mardi un sommet des chefs
d'état de la communauté économique d
afrique de l'afrique de l'ouest s'est
tenue aujourd'hui par visio conférence
présidée par le président du niger pays
voisin du mali et hier devant la presse
à bamako le colonel à 6 mio ita s'est
présenté comme le chef de la junte qui a
renversé président keita la junte
militaire qui affirme ce soir qu'un
président de transition sera mis en
place
ainsi bill ou un militaire précise-t-il
fatoumata abba qui jusqu'ici officier de
l'armée malienne
il est désormais le nouveau chef
autoproclamé du mali le colonel assimi
goïta patron des forces spéciales
malienne est à l'origine du putsch
militaire qui a renversé le président
malien ibrahim boubacar keïta depuis le
ministère de la défense
vingt-quatre heures après la dernière
allocution de l'ex président il
s'est présenté à la nation le président
du comité national ou l'espagne où il
était de mon devoir en puissance les
assume notre soutien par rapport à la
facilité de l'état cette intégration qui
ont mis le pays en coupe du sud et mali
d'abord jean paul hackett
nous avons assuré notre soutien et
l'aide du des propos qui nous rassurer
ni l'union européenne ni la communauté
internationale qui ont fermement
condamné ce coup d'état
le secrétaire général a fermement
condamné la mutinerie militaire qui a
abouti à l'arrestation du président
keita et de membres de son gouvernement
le secrétaire général appelle un
rétablissement immédiat de l'ordre
constitutionnel et de l'état de droit au
mali il réitère ses appels à une
solution négociée et une résolution
pacifique de leurs différends et exprime
son plein soutien l'union africaine et
la cedeao dans leurs efforts pour
trouver une solution pacifique à la
crise actuelle notamment grâce aux bons
offices de son représentant spécial pour
l'opposition réunie au sein du mouvement
du 5 juin
ce coup d'état au contraire permis le
départ du président ibrahim boubacar
kéita et de son gouvernement qu'elle
réclamait depuis des mois mais la
population malienne reste elle partage
et se bat ce qu'il a fait pour le temps
sur le peuple malgache
pourtant le peuple a créé on a demandé à
l'ex-chef d'état ide au bac et écouter
son peuple
il n'a pas voulu dans l'armée c'est
assumé et puis c'est tout moi je vois
pas le problème
le programme
le coup d'état parce que ça n'avance pas
un pays ça nous fait toujours état les
militaires etc à yviers il me promet
beaucoup de choses mais rien ne s'est
passé réellement dans les normes
c'est bien la question qui agite le pays
le colonel assimi goïta et ses hommes
qui se sont imposés par les armes
vont-ils pacifiquement quitter le
pouvoir et il y a huit ans et un autre
coup d'état qui avait fait chuter le
président l'époque amadou toumani touré
depuis 2012 la lutte contre les
djihadistes l'intervention de forces
armées internationales et les problèmes
sociopolitiques rythme la vie du mali
retour en images sur les récentes
grandes dates qui ont marqué le pays
[Musique]
si on n'aime pas me libérer
kevin gameiro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez l'analyse de jean claude félix
tchicaya chercheur à l'institut
prospective et sécurité il ya une main
tendue de la part des militaires à la
société civile et notamment aux
mouvements au mouvement m5 qui demain va
fêter entre guillemets cette victoire
populaire parce que c'est aussi vécue
comme une victoire populaire
démocratique et politique
donc tout de suite après il y aurait une
feuille de route qui n'est pas fait par
les militaires qui sera fait par la
société civile les syndicats la classe
politique
les élites malienne le champ économique
et la communauté internationale qui
j'espère va mieux se plonger sur le pont
de la sociologie et de l'histoire du
mali pour comprendre il est il est vrai
que d'une main la fermeté sur le plan
juridique est tout à fait compréhensible
et de l'autre d'appeler à une
négociation des solutions négociées
démocratique et pacifique qui pourrait
aider à la négociation c'est la
libération du président entre guillemets
sortant que contre a contraint de
démissionner et d'avoir dissout
l'assemblée nationale c'est un geste
fort que d'affaires la junte en côte
d'ivoire les autorités suspendent les
manifestations jusqu'à mi septembre
annonce intervient deux jours avant un
rassemblement contre la candidature
d'alassane ouattara actuel président un
troisième mandat à la semaine dernière
le pays fait face à des manifestations
violentes faisant plusieurs morts et des
dizaines de blessés on regarde le
communiqué des autorités ivoiriennes
[Musique]
le conseil des ministres a décidé de la
suspension des manifestations sur la
voie publique pour les autoriser
seulement dans les enceintes close la
mesure prise dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence en cours est effective
jusqu'au 15 septembre et tire les
conséquences du bilan humain et matériel
des précédentes manifestations et des
risques d'ouverture de poche de conflits
communautaires
les violences pendant trois jours ont
généré 6 morts une centaine de blessés
1500 déplacés internes 69 personnes
interpellées ainsi que de nombreux
dégâts matériels
et on en vient à la situation sanitaire
concernant le kovy 19 dans le monde le
nombre de cas ne cesse d'augmenter un
peu partout et les restrictions se
multiplient dans ce contexte le débat
sur un vaccin obligatoire démarre en
australie le pays est un ancêtre en
cours d'obtention d'un sérum prometteur
grâce au groupe pharmaceutique suédois
britannique astrazeneca parmi de
nombreux mouvement antivaccin le premier
ministre australien persiste et signe
le prochain l'accent sera obligatoire et
gratuit pour tous les australiens
il y a toujours des exceptions à la
vaccination pour des raisons médicales
mais cela devrait être les seuls nous
parlons d'une pandémie qui a détruit
l'économie mondiale et provoqué des
centaines de milliers de morts dans le
monde et en europe alors que l'italie en
régie son plus haut chiffre de nouveau
cas depuis mail oms se veut rassurante
et affirme que l'europe est mieux armé
pour faire face à la pandémie de kobe 19
pour elle les gouvernements sont mieux
préparées la pandémie peut ainsi être
gérée sans imposer un confinement strict
mais les spécialistes recommandent
toutefois de renforcer les mesures
locales pour contrôler les clusters
entre les mesures de base à l'échelle
nationale et les mesures supplémentaires
ciblées
nous sommes en bien meilleure position
pour éradiquer les flancs des virale
localisée nous pouvons gérer le virus et
maintenir l'économie est le systéme
éducatif en marche
on a parlé de l'italie mais de la france
également une progression inédite des
cas de contamination qu'ovide 19 4771
nouveau 4 contamination viennent d'être
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
contre 3776 l'éveil au total plus de
16000 personnes ont été testées
positives sur les sept derniers jours
pour y pallier l'extension du port du
masque obligatoire en extérieur se
poursuit la ville de nice a pris un
nouvel arrêté préfectoral hier soir le
port d'une protection au visage est
désormais obligatoire dans toutes les
villes pour yves buisson
épidémiologistes et président du groupe
cofidis
de l'académie nationale de médecine
paris et mieux préparer la france en
général pour préparer pour affronter
l'épidémie
je pense que nous sommes tout à fait
dans une situation différente de celle
que nous étions au mois de mars et
d'avril puisque maintenant nous avons
les moyens de dépistage nous savons
réagir nous savons faire le traçage
autour des cas et prendre des mesures
très rapidement d'isolement des han han
14/n des patients contaminés par
ailleurs il y a il faut insister là
dessus
des mesures qui restent fondamentales
qui sont les mesures qui visent à
empêcher la propagation du virus de
personne à personne
notamment le port du masque il faut
insister sur ce port du masque dieu sait
qu'on en parle tout le temps on en
revient toujours à cette histoire de
port de masques mais pour l'instant on
n'a rien trouvé de mieux pour empêcher
la transmission d'une personne porteuse
du virus à une personne qui n'a pas le
virus et bien c'est le port du masque
qui est la meilleure méthode bien
entendu il faut y associer les mesures
barrières et le lavage des mains mais le
port du masque doit rester la mesure
fondamentale plus de trois mois après le
déconfinement l'activité repart peu à
peu en france mais ils sont nombreux à
n'avoir jamais arrêté de travailler
c'est le cas des vignerons ils n'ont pas
cessé de prendre soin des vignes au
quotidien il n'en subissent pas moins
les effets de la crise sanitaire
reportage en champagne de renault
parquet avec fierté sa vie vernon
christine chercher viano et viticultrice
et comme des milliers de français elle
ne garde pas un bon souvenir du
confinement ici l'activité ne s'est pas
arrêté et pourtant la viticultrice a
assisté impuissante à l'écoulement de sa
production une baisse de 60 % de chiffre
d'affaires qu'elle ne pourra pas combler
car pour bénéficier des exonérations de
charges patronales prévu par le
gouvernement
il faut avoir enregistré 80 % de pertes
les aides proposées par l'état ne
pourront rien pour son exploitation
déplore christine moi quand j'entends
que certains ont eu des aides alors que
y'a s'était même pas en fonction de
leurs revenus
je parle d'autres secteurs d'activité je
ne dis ben nous on dit juste bhatia
regarde on a continué à travailler et
nous on a besoin de plus de personnel en
étant en conversion bio donc ouais bah
on a vraiment ce sentiment
et en plus on demandait que les charges
patronales et on demandait que sur la
période du coville enfin nous on va
payer
enfin moi c'est le sentiment aujourd'hui
que g7 payer plein pot quoi c'est dans
ce contexte particulier que christine
schaer sévit à nos entamera la fameuse
période de vendanges au mois de
septembre avec une crainte
supplémentaire en début de semaine le
comité interprofessionnel des vins de
champagne a pris une décision qui
pourrait mettre en péril bon nombre
d'exploitations les vignerons ne
pourront pas mettre en bouteille plus de
8000 kilos de raisin par hectare une
idée censé permettre aux vendeurs de
raisin de maintenir un niveau de revenu
acceptable et aux metteurs en marché de
répondre à la demande des clients
une décision difficile à avaler pour
christine schaer saviano non seulement
je vais être limité en volume et en plus
si sûr mais plan comptable il faut
quasiment il faut vraiment très
fortement mépris en fait pour survivre
sachant qu est-ce que j'arriverai à les
vendre d'ailleurs et quand bien même je
commente suffisamment mon prix c'est
assez important
c'est presque du simple au double en
revanche compter sur trois ans et encore
au bout des trois ans il va manquer des
bouteilles 2020 est donc un mauvais cru
pour les viticulteurs français
ironie du sort pour christine chercher
viano la baisse de pollution pendant la
période de confinement a conféré aux
raisins champenois une qualité inédite
ces dernières années des bienfaits dont
christine schaer sevillano ne pourra pas
totalement profiter
julien assange va t'il obtenir l'asile
politique en france sa femme il espère
en tout cas à la solliciter le nouveau
garde des sceaux eric dupond-moretti
pour peser dans la balance
en février dernier la star du barreau
avait déjà annoncé son intention de
demander une audience près d' emmanuel
macron pour répudier la question
incarcéré en angleterre depuis 2019
julian assange devait être extradé vers
les etats-unis pour une peine de 100 75
ans de prison pour françois korber
délégué général de l'association robin
des lois la demande d'asile de julian
assange doit être relancer rapidement
nous travaillons sur le dossier depuis
deux ans et les avocats anglais ne
voulais pas tout de suite faire une
demande d'asile en france
il nous avait dit faut attendre que le
procès se soit déroulé pour ces a
commencé fin février reprend le 7
septembre
donc les avocats anglais voulait
attendre mais à force d'attendre
attendre godot ou d'attendre on sait
trop quoi il ya un risque de ne plus
pouvoir accorder l'asile parce que nous
sommes liés avec l'angleterre par les
accords de dublin avec le brésil ces
accords de dublin n'existeront plus à la
fin de l'année il aura des accords
bilatéraux entre la france l'angleterre
par exemple les villes états unis donc
actuellement si la france accorde
l'asile à julian assage l'angleterre du
fait des traités est obligé de leur
maître de lui permettre de venir en
france
bon donc c'est extrêmement important il
ya six mois et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons repris l'offensive
parce que depuis le mois de février on
n'a plus rien entendu voilà près de 600
jours que la belgique se trouve son
gouvernement une crise politique qui
n'en finit plus dernier rebondissement
le roi philippe a confié au président du
parti libéral flamand la délicate
mission de trouver des partenaires de
majorité à guillaume fils dont la
capacité de former un gouvernement
fédéral depuis le 26 mai 2019
faute de majorité claire aux dernières
élections le roi philippe avait confié
cette mission le 20 juillet dernier à
l'improbable
you bart de wever leader des
nationalistes flamands de la nva et paul
magnette président du parti socialiste
francophone mais n'ayant pas pu obtenir
une majorité parlementaire
ces derniers ont présenté ce mardi leur
démission au roi philippe selon les deux
dirigeants de partis les divergences
avec les libéraux et les écologistes
étaient trop fortes pour trouver un
terrain d'entente
certains ne veulent pas venir quoi qu'il
arrive et d'autres veulent bien venir
mais alors ne veulent pas de mesures
sociales
cela ne sert à rien de s'acharner sur
une piste qui n'a pas de chance de
réussite on sait que tous nous oppose et
vu la gravité de la crise et vu la
situation politique qui ne fait
qu'empirer
nous avons fait cet effort clairement ce
n'était pas une mission évidente
nous avons pourtant réussi à trouver un
accord nous avons trouvé cinq partis
prêts à se rallier à ce projet comme
point de départ des négociations
on avait encore besoin d'un parti d'un
seul parti pour former un gouvernement
majoritaire
ça n'est pas la première fois que le
pays se retrouve dans cette situation
entre 2010 et 2011 les belges n'avaient
pas eu de gouvernement pendant 5 141
jours dans une belgique de plus en plus
divisé où le nord penche vers la droite
à tendance nationaliste et le sud vers
les socialistes le roi philippe a décidé
de confier la mission de la constitution
d'une majorité au président du parti
libéral flamand egberts la charte
celui ci a jusqu'au 28 août pour tenter
de trouver un accord avec les autres
partis s'il ne réussit pas là où ses
prédécesseurs ont échoué
de nouvelles élections pourraient être
convoquées et cela pourrait bien
profiter à la gauche radicale
francophone et à l'extrême droite
flamande
de quoi attiser un peu plus les
divisions au sein du plat pays
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans 30 minutes
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]